[Music]
sorry one more question what do you
think the future of wall street bets is
where does it go
from here with these people like it
seems like they can kind of control the
market with this massive reddit thread
what do you think the future is with
wall street bits
i think they're gonna keep going on i
think that what you're gonna find here
is that the people that
the hot money that came in at the end
that wasn't really committed to what
they're doing will probably you know
will
die out with as soon as there's like
wall street's really good at closing
these gaps and inefficiency so i think
they'll be a lot more careful of
creating these
opportunities that are so easy like game
stop where someone could recognize it
so i think that wall street vets will
continue on they'll be a big follower
they'll have to
they'll have to adapt be more careful
and also choose
a better person than robin a better
company than robin to do that trading
for them because uh
that is not the right platform oh yeah
before you go can you just
tell us what you think happened there
what what do you really think the reason
why robin hood
stopped allowing people to trade or at
least uh
buy was it buy or sell buy buy buy uh
gamestop
fine yeah so when the first day it
happened
i immediately came out in defense of
robin hood because
there are definitely things going on
that that would cause robinhood to have
to
take some protective actions right in
other words
they were going to run out of capital um
they have huge liability if the stock
crashes
but the measures that they took i
thought with draconian and
led me to believe there was other things
going on as well probably
a bit nefarious like getting pressure
from institutions to shut this stuff
down
because they didn't like it they did not
have to stop
trading altogether they could have
what's done called increase the margin
requirement
make it more expensive or more difficult
to borrow the stock
to borrow to buy the stock and that
alone would have done a lot
of what they need to do to get back into
ratio so i think that you're gonna find
there was both things going on they were
certainly acting
to protect themselves uh against any net
capital violations or
losses if the stock crashed they got
caught with losses but also i bet they
were under pressure as well from
from these large hedge funds to not
allow this type of what they consider to
be
collusion and manipulation which is
pretty funny it's really pretty rich
from them
that all day long they're colluding
manipulating stocks yesterday so
you got to laugh at that one 100 yeah
that's what i think
maybe it's a little bit of both right
maybe they ran out of money and then
maybe there was a little bit of a nudge
from citadel is it citadel that
yes and by the way if there's even one
email
that exists or a text that insinuates
that there was pressure oh my god like
it's gonna be
jail time or certainly i mean someone's
going to jail because
i hope listen i don't i don't i'm going
to say what i hope or not but the point
is if that exists
wow that's a big problem for robin hood
really
oh yeah because if they will listen they
did if they're getting pressure and they
yeah to shut down the trading of stocks
that's
flat-out manipulation they're not
actually causing a mark at the full
they're gonna be sued either way they're
gonna get super they're gonna get sued
by every single person that made money
lost money
whether they hadn't accounted robbing it
or not there's gonna be so much
so much legal paper flying around wall
street these next
few months we'll see what happens now
vlad uh well you've been to jail you did
22 months in jail vlad
with that you know long hail hair and
you know
creamy skin how does he how does he last
in jail do you think that they come for
his cheeks
first what do you think he's an
effeminate looking boy
he can
and i don't wish that on anybody right i
really don't okay
but it but the type of jail he would go
to would not be
the type where people are getting uh you
know butt [ __ ] by bubble let's just
say that yeah
it's more like country club jail is that
where you went country
he was locked up with thomas tennis
court
i was very fortunate where i went so uh
i can't complain about that nobody tried
you
nobody tried to jail thomas chong
changed this guy's life he was locked up
with chichen chang
oh [ __ ] if i drop the boris open the
shower
i wouldn't be any more frightened except
if you two guys were together
[Laughter]
the skin looks good your skin looks good
you don't look like you've been stressed
is it botox what's going on it's too
good nah
this is the fountain of middle age i
found you know fountain of middle age
okay well i'm gonna short that stuck
all right jordan thank you so much
you